stop letting people punch you in the
face most people they get up they go to
work for a company that they hate their
waiting for quitting time so they can go
home to their families and their living
for the evenings and weekends they wake
up the next day and they do the same
thing over and over and over again they
do this because they think they have
this safe secure job that this company
is going to look after them and then
when they get fired or downsize or get
their Commission's cut or whatever it is
what do you do you blame the company
right you blame the company so I gave so
much of this company and they didn't
look after me the company is not the
problem the problem is that you gave
your life your destiny to somebody else
you let them make all the decisions for
you if you're not happy with where you
are right now then it's on you to change
that you can't blame anybody but the
person you see in the mirror and the
funny thing is a lot of people they get
up and they go do the same thing again
right you get fired from your job what
do you do you go look for another job so
the whole thing can happen over and over
and over again one of my favorite
stories is from Black & Decker so two
guys one they block when they decorate a
ended up making the power tool company
that has billions and billions of sales
how it started was they were two
employees at a company called Roland
Telegraph they were model employees they
were great employees they weren't
slacking off they were giving a lot of
their effort to the company to make it
better Decker was an engineer and black
was a salesman and one day Roland
refused to match a $25 offer for a
competitor for Decker and he said you
know I've given so much of myself to
this company they won't even match this
offer they don't respect me I'm going to
quit so he quit and instead of doing
what most people would do is go out and
find another job so the whole thing can
happen all over again he said you know
what I'm going to bet on myself this
time I'm going to stop letting companies
punch me in the face and I'm going to
take ownership i'm going to take
responsibility for my life
and he said to create his own company
and he wanted block involved so now I'm
the engineer I need a Salesman so you
approach a block and block was in a
tough spot because he was married he had
kids he had this safe secure job at
Roland and then one day Roland decided
you know what we're going to cut block
sales commissions we're going to cut
your commission they can do that why
because you gave over control and he
said you know what this company doesn't
respect me i'm putting my heart and soul
into it and i'm not getting the returns
so he decided to join decker and they
started Black & Decker and they turned a
twelve hundred dollar investment into
something I made them millionaires and
the company now has over six billion
dollars in sales because they bet on
themselves because they were tired of
letting companies and people punch them
in the face because they took
responsibility and ownership for their
own life so if you're not happy with
where you are right now if you feel like
people keep punching you in the face
stop placing the blame on them start
taking responsibility because only you
can change your life bet on yourself
that's the best bet you can never make
believe if you bet on yourself if you're
tired of having companies punch you in
the face I'd love to hear your story
leave a comment below let me know what
you think you like this video give it a
thumbs up makes gonna do more for you
and click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon